but let me tell you this right now my
friend you want you want to go to the
original ghosting
yeah the first ghost yeah years ago I
bring you to one of my favorite events
of all time
what is a Korean festival in Koreatown
yes one of my best jokes have ever my
life that there we go okay so I take you
to this magnificent event right a
cultural thing yeah I go with my family
yes you know it's like um you took me to
somewhere you're a big deal you're a big
person amongst little people oh yeah
yeah George you're laughing way too
[ __ ] hard all right let's show some
loyalty okay oh he's a very funny man oh
is this an away game for me but
seriously
okay what's up now listen to me okay you
fellas right all right so we we went I
take you to this festival Korean
festival yes and then a year later no
you now a year later like the next day
next day but like I didn't see it for a
year later right you started doing jokes
about me I hurt my feelings jokes were
saying it's a great it's a classic do
the joke I was about how up my friend
Bobby Lee took me to a he's Korean and
he took me to a Korean festival in
Koreatown yeah which is a lot of fun
until you lose your friend have you ever
try to fight a Korean other Koreans like
trying to find a needle in a needle
stack some other ones yeah it's a great
tag yeah yeah that's what great comes to
that yeah let me say something right now
okay
right but the truth of the matter yes
and let's be real about theory let's put
it on the table right why should it send
out a search crew I'm just saying that
like what that means you turn it around
you would have been amazing oh you mean
at the Korean fest yes oh we did find
you you did find me
Yeah right yeah that's not that funny
stay
who lost who did you disappear he just
disappeared I turn around he was like
gone eating like kimchi or some [ __ ]
somewhere and yeah because we drove
there together yeah we all went 13
together who are you there was a chick
there and I think Aron Kader was there
as well that's another shady guy why is
he god I love them I love him I was a
good dude
I missed that old you know that dull old
times
[Music]